again it's like if you have that one day
at a
on a you know having christmas day
or christmas time to myself when i'm
running around working non-stop like
i don't want to then have my holidays
spent running around work you know
seeing everybody non-stop so i
for two or three years just would go to
miami and
like have a vacation of like
yeah yeah before you freak out
well you're a loner too you've talked
about that you like to be alone you
don't you get overwhelmed is that what
it is you get overwhelmed around do you
get overwhelmed on sets
with other people around yeah it's
actually i get it's interesting because
i do get i get overwhelmed around people
a lot of people i pick up people's
energy like i
um i don't know am i overwhelming you
right now oh good good good just want to
make sure
no but it's interesting because when i
know somebody and i feel like safe with
them
it's not an overwhelming thing i'm like
oh like
it's good good um but
a lot like crowds and stuff yeah it's
tough when it's on set
i've learned to block when we're like
you know rolling i i'm able to block out
the noise and
the p like i don't know but i definitely
try to like isolate
and go i don't mean isolate like i'll
try to go in sets that we're not using
that another one did
and just sort of like where's katie
does anyone see katie she's on the uh
the office set she's
she wants to be alone she's gathering
her thoughts do you think people
perceive you as
standoffish at times i i'm not i'm
saying
because you are so like inside yourself
wait what yes and i think that 100 and
i don't know i grew up in a lot of chaos
you know um for whatever you know
without getting into it too much but it
was just at times chaotic
and i definitely think my spirit is more
quiet creative like i love i love
writing um
again love drawing sorry now i'm losing
my train of thought what was your
question
well you know do people perceive you as
can they perceive you or do you think
they could perceive you as someone who
is
standoffish or whatever when you're
really not you're just kind of like
in your own head yeah um
thank you so in high school
and in middle school actually in middle
school i was bullied
by girls and in high school that were
older than me and
i didn't understand why well also
another thing that
i guess they call it resting [ __ ] face
i don't know
um but i guess i remember this girl
came up to me and like got in my face in
the bathroom and was like
you were getting looking at us and
giving us dirty looks or something and i
was like
what and i couldn't quite figure it and
then i realized i wasn't
doing anything other than the sun